something is wrong with the Chinese
economy you can see it at job fairs in
rows of empty half-finished
apartments and in the conspicuous
absence of Chinese tourists
everywhere take unemployment for
instance in just a few short years the
number of 16 to 24 year olds who can't
find work has more than doubled from
about 10% in 2019 to more than 20 this
summer before the government simply
stopped publishing
data if you think the NASDAQ has had a
rough couple of years just have a look
at the Chinese stock market which has
lost about 40% of its value since
2021 or how about Real Estate last year
Chinese land sales reached their lowest
level this
Century one especially desperate
developer is enticing new home buyers
with $70,000 worth of I kid you not gold
bars consumption is down deflation has
set in and for the first time in our
lifetimes its population has begun to
shrink the question is no longer when
but whether its economy will surpass
America's for the past two decades most
agree that the West is declining and the
East is rising but increasingly it feels
as though the East has risen are we
witnessing Peak
China sponsored by nebula the exclusive
home to my original series China
actually the 2008 financial crisis
should have been disastrous for China
the United States is its largest trading
partner thousands of Chinese factories
and millions of workers rely on American
consumers who suddenly found themselves
out of work work and on the hook for
mortgages they couldn't
afford yet by 2009 China was back on
track it was in fact the first major
economy to recover while the US Japan
Germany and the rest of the world
contracted China's economy actually grew
and by nearly double digits no
less 10 years later China was ground
zero for the co 19
pandemic this time supply and demand
were disrupted Factory and service
workers had no ability to work from home
but once again Beijing defied
expectations it not only weathered the
storm but was as before the very first
country to recover soon its exports
soared to Heights never before
seen in short no one has ever won by
betting against the Chinese
economy so how does China do it it's
simple when in doubt it
builds roads Bridges skyscrapers
stadiums airports whatever this
is it goes something like this first
Beijing makes borrowing money laughably
easy it lowers interest rates and drown
state owned Enterprises with generous
subsidies when money is free and losses
so socialized you'd have to be an idiot
not to build highways Bridges and
tunnels even if they lead
nowhere much of this investment
obviously is
unproductive but it creates jobs and
raises the country's GDP just the
same now for a long time this Whirlwind
of construction actually made sense when
dong Shia ping Rose to power in the
1970s China was poor underdeveloped and
in desperate need for even the most
basic
infrastructure the simplest two-lane
road or singl story school was a massive
improvement from nothing just to catch
up with the rich World China needed to
build first and think
later in 2009 Al jazer ran a story about
ordos China's Eerie ghost City in the
desert here in this empty pemin Village
it proclaimed was irrefutable evidence
of a housing bubble
today ordos is quiet but far from empty
with about 2 million residents in
total more recently in 2017 CNN
published this image with the headline
China's Metro station in the middle of
nowhere readers around the world laughed
at this hilarious white
elephant then a mere 2 years later the
station had transformed into this and
laughter was replaced with awe more
often than not critics were wrong and
demand eventually caught up with Supply
as Millions migrated to
cities and yet this can't go on
forever by definition to maintain
economic growth China has to keep
investing more and more meanwhile the
Returns on that construction are getting
worse and
worse this is China's capital to Output
ratio essentially how productive it
investment 20 years ago it took $4 worth
of construction to generate a $1 return
today it takes about
12 China is already a middle inome
country with Rich country
infrastructure with 25,000 Mi of
High-Speed Rail and 3 million mi of
highway it's simply running out of
things to build with nearly every
obvious opportunity exhausted China is
resorting to increasingly questionable
projects this for example is the tallest
bridge in the world at 1,800 ft above
the ground and measuring 2300 ft long
it's an architectural and Engineering
Marvel impressive absolutely
economically sound doubtful it's located
not in Shanghai Chongqing or Hong Joo
but in China's equivalent of rural
Mississippi guo is the fourth poorest of
the country's 31 provinces and
provincial level cities but its per
capita GDP of
$7,700 hasn't stopped it from building
about 500 new bridges in Just 2 years
many of which are among the world's
tallest now perhaps this $150 million
bridge in the mountains will be the next
ordos or Metro station quote in the
middle of nowhere perhaps it will Spring
to life and transform the local local
economy given China's track record it
would be foolish to bet against any one
project but it would also be foolish to
think this could go on
indefinitely think about it like this
taking on debt is perfectly normal
sometimes that debt takes years to
generate returns also perfectly fine but
when debt continues growing faster than
GDP we know there's a serious
problem previously China would build say
a new airport represented here by an
increase in debt and it might sit empty
for a time while demand for flights
caught up with Supply we might read
articles in the meantime about this
wasteful ghost airport but after a few
years we'd inevitably see a
corresponding rise in GDP represented
here so far so good then starting around
2009 we start to see debt and GDP diver
Verge here debt is still boosting GDP
but by a lot less we can see this more
clearly by dividing the debt line by the
GDP line the two grow at pretty much the
same rate that is sustainably until 2009
when debt starts growing much faster at
that point china keeps building more
highways and airports but demand never
catches up this is the Dilemma China
finds itself in today the old model the
only one it's ever known no longer
works now there are only four ways to
increase
GDP investment which as we've already
seen isn't a viable option government
spending which is more or less a
constant and exports which the Us and
other countries are actively trying to
reduce that leaves only one route
forward consumption in other words China
needs to somehow convince people to
spend more money and needless to say
gentle persuasion is not something the
party has been known to excel at as you
can see not only has it thus far failed
to do so but it's actually made negative
progress Chinese consumers spend less
than 40% of their GDP Americans by
contrast spend nearly 70% Europeans over
50%
and the average global consumer
55 the main reason is real estate until
recently buying property was the tried
andrue investment strategy for middle
class
households save prodigiously pull
together money from family and every
Urban couple could buy an apartment or
more often two or three and live the
Chinese dream most of these homes were
sold before construction had even
finished finished allowing developers to
immediately take these down payments and
start building more all it took
therefore was one set of buyers to stop
making payments last year and the whole
system came crashing
down for two decades the country was
taught that property was the only safe
investment then property stopped being a
safe investment no wonder Chinese
consumers are
worried now the problem is one of
confidence it's simple really when you
receive your paycheck how do you decide
whether to save or spend it generally
speaking you spend it when you're
confident you'll keep receiving more and
you'll save it if you aren't so
sure well Chinese consumers aren't so
sure in the last 4 years they've
absolutely stuffed their bank accounts
to the brim with money and cut back on
big flashy purchases like cars TVs and
and Furniture they're still traveling
but mostly domestically they're still
spending but mostly on
sales so naturally in order to
incentivize purchases companies are
lowering their
prices these lower prices and therefore
profits are leading to layoffs and
reduced
wages finally these layoffs are making
consumers even less confident and as a
result less likely to go shopping
completing the
cycle until and unless China interrupts
this positive feedback loop it will be
forced to accept lower economic
growth now all right let's put things in
perspective Between 1979 and today China
saw what the World Bank calls the
fastest sustained expansion by a major
economy in
history those four decades were
anomalous they weren't sustainable and
they were simply never going to last its
economy is still growing albeit much
more slowly its middle class is still
700 million people strong and its
military is still the world's second
largest China is not going away to argue
otherwise is to overcorrect from the
prior era of optimism to make the same
mistake in the opposite direction but
the Lightning Fast growth that led to
speculation about an Asian century is
going away and there's very little it
can do at the very heart of this
slowdown are
demographics as long as the population
was growing China could build almost
aimlessly confident there would be a
steady supply of bodies to fill every
ghost City airport and
Highway but as of last year China is now
actively shrinking its birth rate has
already dropped to the lowest level in
the world just 1.09 children per woman
and by 2030 the labor force is expected
to decrease by about 1% every year one
of the great Mysteries behind this
demographic collapse is why China kept
the one child policy around for so long
until
2016 surely its leaders had to have
known the population would begin to
shrink so why then were families still
prohibited from having more children
find out the answer to this question in
the latest 20 minute 7th installment of
my nebula original series China actually
here's a quick preview this would make
it the single most effective National
policy in history and anyone could see
that it just wasn't going to work this
was no ordinary period in Chinese
history the most damning evidence comes
in the form of CrossCountry comparisons
there's much more to this story China
actually is and will will always be
exclusive to nebula the creator-owned
streaming platform nebula is also home
to Originals like real life L's deep
dives into recent Wars modern conflicts
Wendover Productions Logistics of X
Series explaining how things like coal
mining and search and rescue work and
real engineering's beautifully rendered
Battle of Britain with a nebula
subscription you also get access to
nebula plus bonus content nebula first
early releases and nebula classes where
you can go behind the scenes with some
of your favorite
creators you can get all that for 50%
off by signing up for an annual plan
with the link on screen now or by
clicking the link in the description at
just
$2.50 a month that's a pretty fantastic
deal if you ask
me